Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie. What is happening?  There's new Doctor Who footage so this is
going to be a breakdown of that. Lots of
classic Daleks that we haven't seen in
awhile.  There is like a hierarchy,  so I'll
explain what all the different Daleks
look like and we get a good shot of
Skaro which is really cool.
Whole lot of Maisie Williams, too.  What I'm going to do is I'm just going to take this scene by scene
like some of these scenes are stitched
together but they're broken up across
the trailer.   And if you've never seen Doctor Who before I did do like a series 9
beginner's guide.  I'll put a link to that
in the description so you guys are
caught up.  It doesn't start till
September 19th and it's all on Netflix. So
there's line the trailer where the
Daleks say, "What is happening?" and the
Doctor just says, "Business as usual."
That's what a lot of these early shots
imply: just him in the TARDIS, business as
usual
him and Clara out having adventures. That's one of the
core ideas a Series 9 is that it's not
so much about them getting used to each
other it's about them being okay with
each other like Clara being okay with the
new doctor and then just out and having
fun
like they should be.  Nevermind the search for
Gallifrey and the fact that Missy is
still alive and she's tailing them. So
here's a glorious shot of this Maisie
Williams episode. She's in a two-part
episode it will be full two hours
Supposedly part one is called "the girl
who died", part 2 is called "the woman who
lived",  so that might be who Maisie
Williams' character is.  I know everyone
wants to be Susan or Jenny, like the Doctor's daughter.   Steven Moffat did one of those things
where he's like, "she's not that person
you think she is, or I might be lying" if
you've been a longtime fan of Who you
know about Moffat lies meme, so you
can take that take that as you will like
he could possibly be lying, she could
possibly be Susan or Jenny, but I i still
kinda think that she's a new character
the episode though it looked like it
takes place entirely in period so if we're
gonna be on earth in this episode of
these two episodes then it'll be like
Robots of Sherwood, with fantasy stuff
in a real environment because there's
this Thundercats standing next to her in
this alternate shot and it looks like he
can breathe fire.  These are some of the new
monsters they created for Series 9.
most of the monsters are new this year
but there are few familiar ones. The cool
thing about this Maisie Williams episode
is it also has a character named Merlin
Odin, and Struan Rodger who did the
face of BOE during New Earth and Gridlock
everybody wave to John Barrowman over on
Arrow season four. And oh look,
it's a dragon, what a coincidence!
I wonder how Amelia Clarke feels about this? I'm gonna call it Nymeria until we get the actual name in
the episode. No idea what this hallway is
this could imply a lot of different
things. Eyeball hands look amazingly
terrifying - mysteriously similar to the
Sibylline Sisterhood from the Fires of
Pompeii so this actually might be that
fires of Pompeii episode.  In the original
conception of the series, during
Series four, it was intended to explain
why the Doctor can change history
sometimes and sometimes he can't.  But the way Moffat explained
it in series 9 is that they're going to
revisit that so that they can explain
why the 12th Doctor's face looks like this
character's face. If you remember this
is actually one of the characters the
Karen Gillan played before she was
recast as Amy Pond.  This actually looks
like Joivan Wade, he's actually coming
back.  If you remember he was in last
season's episode Flatline
the one where everybody got sucked into two dimensions
I'm assuming that he's reprising the
same character so I'm really enjoying
the "oh sh*t" face here.  Like, oh god, not
again
Zygons of course. They're actually they're
gonna play a big role in this series
they're getting a two-parter themselves, too.  Osgood is coming back in this episode
they didn't explain how because
supposedly Missy killed her during Series 8
but it's going to be like a U.N.I.T. episode
so we'll see Kate Stewart and like a long time
Doctor Who monster actor coming back
his name is Aidan Cook but he starred in
the Rings of Akhaten, Hide, Nightmare in
Silver, The Day of the Doctor, and Time of
the Doctor.  Clara smirking with a
bazooka and her motorbike which we
haven't seen a little while.  This might
be the same motorbike from the fiftieth
anniversary.  She's dressed all in black
so either she's on some sort of hard core
mission or something weird is going on
with her. There have been seasons of
Doctor Who where companions wear like
almost the same outfit for the entire
series.  And then there have been times when they
change outfits all the time. Because
Clara was a school teacher and she was
going on dates with Danny Pink, she got a
bunch of different costume changes.  A lot
of you guys were asking me on Twitter if this was
Gallifrey.  No this is Skaro from before
the Dalek war, before the plant was
ravaged.  This shot is actually in homage
to a classic first Doctor episode called
The Daleks. They went to Skaro and you get
this far away shot of a Dalek city looks
just like this.  This looks like it's just further
inside that episode, inside this the Skaro
episode. This looks like one of the new
monsters. We don't really know much about
it but this reminds me of Tony Stark
the first Iron Man movie - "come at me bro"
Clara, Missy, and the Doctor having some
fun. This looks like a follow up on one
of those eyeball hands so I'm guessing
that that shows up in a Missy episode.
It just feels right that Missy should get
all that really creepy stuff.  So here we
see a red Dalek and a couple blue Daleks
the blue ones are kinda like intermediate
Daleks that served this red one
this kind of reminds me of the supreme
Dalek the last time I saw him was during
the Davros episodes in the Medusa Cascade,
so this this might be like a completely
different Dalek, it just visually it looks
like that Dalek.  Here's another new monster
really don't know anything about him,
just looks very sophisticated and
terrifying.  This is another new monster -
little more humanoid as I still think of
like most villains as monsters
especially if they're wearing a lot of
prosthetics.  This is kind of a funny way
to end the trailer just because the
Doctor's strict No Hugging policy so they
probably included this just a show that
he softening up just a little bit. And so
that's it.  So just reminder it's coming
out the 19th September that's a Saturday.
It's a Saturday's show if you haven't
watched it before. I'll be doing videos
each week for it I'll try and do Q&A is
if I can but it's gonna bump up with
Walking Dead and my Game of Thrones stuff
on Sunday so I'll figure it out.  But I will
do give away actually all going start a
new round of the giveaway now.  All you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video.  I'll just let it run
until we get like another Doctor Who
trailer, which should come in about two
weeks now that we are getting really really close.  Let
me know what do you think about all
these new Doctor Who monsters? Really the
biggest things in my mind are the big Zygon episode, finding out what's going on
with Osgood, what's going on with Missy
and what her plan for the Doctor is, the mystery
of Maisie Williams and if she's ever
going to come back, and visiting Skaro
again. "What is happening?" In case you
haven't seen it you can click here for
my Doctor Who beginner's guide to just a
couple episodes that I recommend based
on core concepts and you can click here
to learn all about the new stuff that's
happening with The Flash and Arrow, they
just dropped a couple bombs yesterday. thank you
so much watching everybody, let's high five, I'll see
you guys tonight